common misconceptions about what a
writer should do after their script is
finished let's see one is getting your
script registered with the WGA versus
having it copyrighted versus mailing it
to yourself I've seen many writers who
still believe that if you mailing your
script to yourself that counts as a
copyright no it does not it will not
hold up in court the only thing that
will hold up in court is a copyright
where it has an official document
attached to it it said this script is
doc was copyrighted on this date WG a
registration is still better than
mailing it to yourself but it's not
quite as good as a copyright especially
with when they change their copyright or
their registration and stuff only goes
like overall it doesn't go like per
draft where's the copywriting you don't
want copyright each each thing that way
you get proof of it it's a little more
expensive to copyright but it's the
safest thing if one of those very rare
stealing's ever happen
what's a paranoid screenwriter the
people who are afraid that their stuff
is gonna get taken people who won't send
their stuff out to competitions won't so
there's about the producers without an
NDA
never ever send an NDA to a producer be
like oh you can't read my script until
you know they'll just give you your NDA
back you're like well then I don't need
to read your script which I've met
several people who think that they need
to send an NDA out in order to get
produced to read know the producer is
not gonna send that entity you need to
sign an NDA for the producer possibly if
you if you want to work on the project
that they're needing the hire writer for
you know to save there but say you're
not then gonna take their idea and go
write it yourself without them but they
will not sign an NDA for you
[Music]
you